you
[Music]
hi I'm Lewis CTO dateable couple of
character off occasions when I'm talking
about sequel I'm talking about the
language sequel no sequel vs. no sequel
and we're going to use some of these
metaprogramming method language
definitions a little loosely okay so why
do we do this we want a scalable
solution for managing data
transformation processes that works
right everybody working with that data
so our entire data team we love sequel
for this it's growing in popularity
thanks to more and how data warehouses
sequel scales extremely well it's a
common language for the whole team it's
probably the closest thing we're gonna
have something which everybody
throughout the whole team can understand
it scales extremely well and it's quite
nice to develop with when you develop
sequel you can run that query
immediately when we do a similar thing
in code we have to build and deploy and
then find out that our code doesn't
compile but it does have some problems
so sequel primary doesn't scale from a
kind of organizational perspective
without some additional tooling to help
it do that so fundamentally the problem
here is it's hard to adopt software
engineering best practices when you're
building sequel based data pipelines
sequel isn't a programming language as
such things like releases version
control writing unit tests or easing
code between queries is tricky to do
with just pure sequel
so in order to understand how to fix
these problems that stick a little bit
into what exactly sequel is first so
sequel is a declarative query language
declarative programming is when you say
what you want and imperative programming
is when you say how to get what you want
so it typically if you're running some
Python or some JavaScript you're doing
imperative programming you're telling
the computer how to manipulate the data
in order to produce an output in sequel
we don't really do that we more tell
what we're trying to achieve we want to
sum these numbers we want to group these
numbers and that's quite a fundamental
difference it's a limitation but it also
has many advantages so looking at the
advantages of being declarative sequel
queries can be parallelized as a result
every data warehouse or sequel engine
has some kind of query planner which can
do fairly impressive optimizations and
it can also paralyze computations like a
sum across thousands of machines if you
compare this the kind of optimizations
you can apply in an imperative
programming language like C++ compiler
they're far more restricted and what
they can do they're usually quite
localized and low-level optimizations
additionally sequel statements generally
don't have any side-effects they can
cool when they execute they can't call
other api's they can't mutate stay out
of what they're actually doing and
obviously can delete and insert into
tables we also have a nice benefit that
even though it is very possible to write
a sequel query that will never term it
terminate and I'm sure many of you have
generally as a like theoretically we can
we know that it must terminate at some
point
so there's a few exceptions that
generally sequel is not a programming
language there's a few features that it
will shorten there's no iteration or
recursion you can't write a for loop in
sequel you can do some of the stuff with
some sequel features like recursive CTS
or flavors of sequel like T sequel which
allow you to actually introduce control
flow although we wouldn't necessarily
recommend that you do that so it's
declarative and it's also static it
can't kind of mutate itself okay so
let's look at some code examples this is
a pretty simple sequel query which takes
a table and groups and sums by a age
bucket we can't reuse this code very
easily and there's a few reasons but
main reason is that the input is fixed I
think we often think of a sequel query
as a function but it's not a very useful
function because it has no parameters we
can't change the input to the function
and this causes a lot of problems around
code reuse it's better to think of a
sequel statement as a block of code
which is just going to execute for the
same reasons we also have a problem
writing testable code the same query if
we wanted to actually write a unit test
for it would be very difficult to do
because we couldn't pass in some mock
data step so that we could actually have
a kind of self-contained unit test and
again this is because there are no
parameters here there aren't any
variables it's just a block of code so
we need some kind of function or
parameterize functions in order to be
able to write tests
okay so another example and we have a
real use case for this ourselves is we
want to be able to write for loops and
iterative code I would love it if I
could write some sequel like this but
sadly I can't but we'll show you how you
can do this in a bit this is an example
for dealing with gdpr data we have a lot
of tables containing user information
derived tables which are transformations
Barroso's tables if somebody's going
wants to be removed gives us a gdpr
deletion requests you want to go and
make sure that you remove that user from
all of the relative relevant tables in
this case there's just three there might
be hundreds you don't want a copy paste
the same delete statement into a hundred
different queries so they for loop would
be extremely useful here but obviously
this does not exist even if it did exist
the there's no variables as well so this
would be kind of hard to accomplish okay
so how do we fix these problems
metaprogramming I copy pasted all of
this from Wikipedia but in general
better programming is a technique in
which we can treat other programs as our
data we can also use this to move
competition from runtime to compile time
which is kind of the same thing and this
is exactly what we're going to do with
sequel in order to make it more
expressive and to solve some of the
problems we just looked at we don't want
to throw the baby out with the bathwater
we like sequel for a number of reasons
we think it's a great way to develop
data transformation pipelines we just
need to fix it in a few ways so that we
can apply software entering best
practices as we develop sequel so that
this approach will actually scale as our
team grows as the company grows and
we're dealing with hundreds maybe
thousands of data sets
okay so let's look at an example of meth
programming and how we can solve that
fundamental problem of our sequel it's
just a block of code and it's not a
function that we can parameterize them
and reuse some kind of JavaScript that
doesn't really matter we have our
original sequel query in the left if we
can wrap this up in a function which
takes some input parameters and then
generates us a query so that we can
change the input or we could change the
in this case bucket size then we can
start to do some interesting things and
we can reuse this code in multiple
queries or we can write a unit test for
this sequel this is a fairly simple
example and I imagine that this in this
case the query is simple enough that you
would want to just rewrite it anyway but
there are probably some there are some
more complex situations for example
dealing with complex operations loading
data in and out of redshift for example
these can get quite complex there's may
be validation logic you want to add or
lots of promises that you might be able
to control and so this can become
extreme useful this is effectively a
code generator our function it's a code
generator it's going to generate us a
sequel query which we can then go and
and execute this is a pretty key step in
everything we're gonna do and all of the
fixes we're going to apply and how much
programming really helps us solve these
problems so we won't code reuse we want
some imperative iterative recursive
programming we're going to want to
introduce some basic control flows and
if statements only run this statement if
this other statement fails or passes we
also want to maintain some of the
benefits of sequel as a declarative
query language and particularly at
runtime
something that we would like to avoid is
arbitrary imperative user code executing
at runtime and as you'll see in a second
our solution here is official a lot of
that into a compilation step okay so
data form is a open source framework for
managing and managing your sequel we
have a we can think of it like a method
language and a compilation step to
produce sequel based graphs of actions
that we want to perform against our
warehouse and we have a number of
abstractions inside the framework which
makes it easy to develop currently we
support bigquery redshift post grows as
your data warehouses a few others in the
horizon presto Athena
everything's Evert the entire frameworks
written in typescript it's open source
you can check it out and I'll put some
links at the end of the talk okay so the
framework overview we want to make it
easy to write parametrize sequel we want
to make it easy for you to define
directed acyclic graphs I imagine any
data processing tools you use use some
notion of DAGs the data flow model it
makes a lot of sense with age pipelines
and we're not doing anything different
here there's a few other features and
abstractions that we can add in as well
so a thing that comes up a lot for us is
testing we are going to look at some
unit tests but also runtime assertions
so if your data pipeline produces some
invalid data or even in a staging or
production environment you want to be
able to detect that and you want to be
able to either alert somebody or maybe
you want to hold the pipeline we have
first-class support unit tests and a
number of other things that we know are
quite important to building a scalable
data
stack such as being able to write
documentation managing environments and
different releases so this is our this
is our approach to solving many of those
problems with sequel by introducing this
compilation step we think of it a lot
like how you would compile another
programming language like C we have a
number of different phases and they're
all there for very good reasons so on
the far left here this is what you would
effectively call the language we have a
JavaScript API in which you can do
pretty much anything we also have a
sequel X format which is a kind of a
mash up where you can primarily write
pure sequel but provide JavaScript based
templating and configuration blocks for
you to provide metadata about the query
that you're developing your a lot to
write imperative code a you can write
for loops and all of that good stuff to
build out your graph so we can sort on
this promise you saw before it's also a
sandbox environment I have a sliding
this so I'll skip it for now but it's a
it's quite an important thing that we
added to the framework
you don't want typically when you
compile any other language you don't
have the ability to write make Network
or requests or read the file system at
compilation time and one of the reasons
this would be bad is because you want
compilation to be extremely quick a lot
of these design decisions allowed us to
keep compilation of even very large data
form projects - under a second and that
has a lot of benefits for developing
otherwise you could spend a little time
waiting for us three things there's a
the output of the compilation process is
a compiled graph I mentioned before that
we want to keep some of the advantages
of having a declarative static query
language which secretly
and the compiled graph in our case is
static and fully declarative it's an
extra row of actual pure sequel and in a
JSON object which you can inspect and
work with directly if you wanting once
we have a compiled graph which kind of
tells us everything every operation or
action inside our data warehouse we then
need to go to a final step which we call
build which is I guess similar to a
normal sovereign kind of build process
in the build step we actually introduce
information from your data warehouse so
information such as what tables exist
and we use this to generate the final
sequence statements that will actually
get executed so this can take a bit
longer because we need to make Network
requests but as a user this is generally
hidden from you you don't have to worry
too much about it and you're just
worrying about the compilation process
okay so this is a example of a stageful
operation or action that's done in two
different ways
so I mentioned we have both Java scripts
and a sequel X format on the Left we are
looking to publish the table it's a very
simple publish operation we want to
create a new table in our data warehouse
and we want it to just be a pure copy of
the user's table on the right we have a
sequel X version of exactly the same
thing and in this case you're primarily
writing sequel but you have additional
language features in to define some of
the properties that you would otherwise
do via the JavaScript API if your team's
used to write integral this is usually
where we recommend most people start and
for some of the more advanced use cases
with the JavaScript API you can do
slightly more interesting things
sodid forms abstracting some of these
ideas some of these common operations
away
given that the primary problem is
solving here is about building and
managing a nice clean consistent set of
data in your warehouse publishing new
tables and new views of that data is
probably the thing that we do the most
this is a example of how that code gets
turned into a compiled graph so this is
just a piece of Jason describing this
action we've got a name we've got the
table that we're going to create we've
got the pure sequel the Select star
statement and and the type that was the
table entry so two things have happened
during this compilation process which
are worth pointing out in both of these
examples we have a piece of JavaScript
in there where we're calling a function
called ref and passing it in a string in
this case we're aiming to reference
another table that we've created as part
of our data form project when we compile
this code we end up with that reference
function being expanded into a full
table reference that we can actually
which is just pure sequel we've also
added the table that we depended upon to
a list of dependencies and into some
metadata about the action this is what
allows us to build up the directed graph
and make sure that we can execute
operations in the correct order
there's no create table statement at
this point this is still just a select
query we're generally when you want to
build a table the primary thing you want
to think about is writing that query and
the boilerplate around that isn't
something you necessarily have to worry
about in in some warehouses this is
simple we just append something like
create or replace in other warehouses
this can get a bit more complex so
sometimes you need to deal with
temporary tables and transactions and as
users you don't really want to have to
think about that so this gets
packaged up in an abstraction so we can
take our compiled graph and we can run
the project and we can do this all via
the online interface and the build steps
run during that process and this will
first describe all of the actions that
going to run when we run compile and and
we can get the JSON out from that if we
want to and then when we actually run we
will go and execute the full statements
create table statements in your
warehouse okay so it's basically a
sequel compiler we take your user code
we take your sequel X Files JavaScript
and we generate this kind of runtime
format which is the compiled graph so
that we can then execute those actions
in your warehouse we can write any code
we want during compilation phase but at
runtime the actions that we perform a
fully declarative and Static they can't
change dynamically at any point there
are not benefits for this it makes a lot
easier for us to reason about our data
pipelines we know that they're going to
terminate eventually it means we can do
things like validation at the point of
compilation and rays warnings very
quickly it's not it's unlikely that
you're going to get in a situation where
you try and run your thing and after an
hour of execution some user code throws
an exception and the whole pipeline
falls down we can be confident that
that's not the case because we've pushed
all of those operations into a pre
compilation step there are some control
structures that we keep at runtime the I
think the key thing here is they're not
iterative you can't do loops or anything
like that you've basically got the
equivalent of if statements you can
decide whether to run something else if
something passes this is the only
control structure we provide it's
somewhat opinionated but it does mean
that as these pipelines scale and
perhaps you have a number of people
developing them or contributing to them
who
on software engineers or unable to
reason about what sensible to do at this
stage this kind of makes sure that no
situations like that ever really arise
so one thing we want from our
compilation step and again we would run
this if we were compiling any other
language is we want it to be
reproducible if we have the same input
the same sets of files and disk and we
compile the project we should get the
same output that's one of the reasons
why we sandbox this the compilations
stage and the user code and it can't
make any external API calls you also
have to be a bit careful yourself you
don't want to use non dominant
deterministic code in this step
ideally in most compilers this would be
impossible but because we're allowing
you to write arbitrary Java scripts you
could do this so you do still have to be
a little bit careful okay so that's our
high-level solution to the problem and
then let's have a look at some of the
use cases and real-world use cases that
this actually helps to solve and some
code samples of how this works for loops
we can now write for loops we can take
our gdpr
example from the past and we can just
actually write this in java scripts we
can define a set of actions which will
clean up certain tables we can define
the the query in this situation the
query is a lambda function we have a
context for that query and we can call
some methods on that context this allows
us to do the templating and
parameterization that we wanted to do
all of this gets expanded into actual
final sequel and a static set of sequel
queries during the compilation phase so
this for loop is no longer exists after
we've compiled the project
so unit testing sequel unit testing I
don't think that's the thing but it is
now a thing and in order to do this we
needed again there's parameterize
queries going back to our age
distribution example before we can write
that exact code we can define a function
we can have a parameter for the input we
can use this to actually publish a table
we obviously do want to do this
transformation or aggregation so there's
an example of that code below but in tej
form we can also write the test so we
can use our sequel query generating
function we can pass it in some mock
data in this case I've just written a
union or Select statement you can do
this programmatically as well and we can
tell they to form what we expect the
output to be so we mock the input we
define the output that we expect and
this is a self-contained sequel query it
doesn't have any dependencies on other
tables we still need to run it in a
warehouse for a few reasons firstly
every warehouse is a little bit
different secondly it's hard to write a
sequel query which actually checks for
pure equality between two tables these
can all be run in parallel so all of the
tests that you define in digital project
can be executed at the same time because
they are self-contained and don't
interact with each other okay so another
cool example if you're dealing with
multiple environments you have a
production environment you have a
staging environment sometimes these
production environments process a lot of
data and can create extremely slow it's
not uncommon to see pipelines which take
6 or 12 hours and you probably don't
want to be running that in a staging
environment because it's gonna take you
a long time to work out if you've broken
something so you can sample data in a
staging environment again because our
sequel queries are parameterised we can
actually do that and change generate
different sequel based on the parameters
passed into the compilation
so this is a little bit different
because we're not my sequel query sort
of function but we're accessing kind of
global States at this point all
properties of parameters passed into the
compiler in order to do this this also
isn't a great example of single query
because we're using R and so it's not
entirely reproducible but you could
write this in another way so I mention
this before loading data from s3 to do
that in redshift there are a number of
number of operations that we need to
create and I've shown some of them on
the right here
but in practice our actual libraries to
do this need to do a lot more we've
defined temp tables we create them we
rename tables and swap them out so on
the Left we have a function that we can
call to actually generate all of the
sequel for us which means if we have a
lot of data sets that we want to load in
from s3 we can do in a consistent way
and we don't have to rewrite the same
queries over and over again this also
means we can add in things like
validation into our API s if we want to
enforce consistency between the ways in
which people load data from s3 then we
can we can actually do that in our
compilation step and throw errors which
will be surfaced if they've been used
incorrectly this also allows us to
redefined ap is that we're using so
obviously there is a way to do a copy
command enriched shift and it has some
parameters you can pass the this can be
wrapped up for your Inge and use cases
cool ok so I've talked a lot about the
framework and how we designed it we also
have a web platform tayfun web which is
a IDE for data form projects so a new
language is great but that an IDE it can
be frustrating and slow to develop
against and this is actually really one
of the biggest drivers to us building
this framework
specifically to us building it in the
way that we did we know ourselves that
we are more productive when we have a
good to develop an environment to work
in and we wanted to be able to provide
the same for people working with our
framework development speed matters
that's one of the advantages of sequel
that there's a very fast turnaround time
to develop a test and actually execute a
sequel query we want to be able to give
that to the entire team so so the idea
for different projects it compiles your
sequel project in real time similar to
other IDs do you get warnings if you may
make errors or break validation rules
you can execute arbitrary sequel and
preview the results the web IDE also
integrates with git so if particularly
if you have people in your data team who
are less comfortable with the command
line you can use the git integration to
manage pull requests and create commits
manage measure conflicts all this kinds
of stuff
there's also everything else you'd
expect from a web-based platform for
data pipelines scheduling orchestration
we mentioned some of the documentation
features of the open-source framework
and there is also a data catalog built
in so this is the ID it's built around
Monaco which is an open-source version
of the S code we have our main sequel in
the center which is a sequel X file we
compile everything in real time and it's
visible on the right so we can see the
full compiled query we can see if the
query validated against the warehouse we
can see the dependencies that we've
introduced the type of table that's
going to be created and we can preview
the results and at the top you can see
some of the can get integration features
and a list of files in there so one of
the benefits of this as well as we can
build up a dependency graph during
compilation and we can visualize that so
you can visualize the dependencies
between all of these different actions
this is an example I think from our
actual internal data form projects these
graphs can get pretty big that the
visualization is extremely useful to try
to understand how everything is
interacting pacifically when you might
be writing java scripts and also
generating a lot of these actions this
is enabled by the framework design and
the fact that we do have this static
compiled graph that we can then
visualize after the compilation step so
finally there's a catalog as well on the
left here we've got an example of how
you can document a dataset and just
provide descriptions to fields and the
table itself and this is useful with
data governance as an issue or if you
have so many tables that you need to be
able to share this with everyone the
team cool so thank you this is V links
here for the framework for a doc site I
put examples from this talk of the
actual code snippets in a repo so you
can check that out and compile and play
around with that because of the web ID
which is free to try or free to use for
individuals and there's some good
example projects on there that you can
click around and play around with to get
an idea of what exactly the data format
looks like
I want to ask you somebody's bound to
take this and use with unrested data so
what about sequel injection how do you
guard against it because you cannot
translate everything into sequel query
parameters because your parameters are
not like sequel query parameters like
from clause and cetera do you mean
sequel injection is in terms of like as
security yes yes yeah so so ultimately
this is when using this form this is
your project and your developers writing
that code because of this compilation
process is kind of sandbox
nothing can really get injected in given
that you have prioritized these sequel
queries yeah you could inject I guess
bad things in this case but the only
people who could write that code would
be developers on your team so I guess
it's the same way is probably the same
risk in that the developers on your team
are writing code they could mess
everything up if they wanted to there's
no there's an external threat from
parametrizing these sequel functions
nice talk I'd like to know why did you
choose JavaScript over Python like gvt
for example yeah yeah good question so
obviously Python is the GoSee language
if you're developing data pipelines so
there are there are a few reasons here I
think one of these one of the only
reasons it was around speed we really
want to keep that compilation time down
and make sure it's very fast I think
possibly a bigger reason for us was
sandbox in the compilation process is
happening in the sandbox and we we can
do that in JavaScript this is actually
really annoyingly hard to do with - we'd
also had some - so one thing I should
say is actually when we develop data
form we'd actually started out building
an ID for DBT projects and that's how
the project actually started that we
wanted to solve that development process
and speed up the development process so
we kind of moved away from DBT for a few
reasons
but yeah sandboxing speed we want to
just make sure that everything
it's really fast I think yeah there was
also some other minor practical reasons
like our whole stack and web front-end
and the ID itself is all in typescript
and having a unified language across the
whole stack there is nice there's
there's less of a reason to use Python
as a language given that we're never
actually processing data so that value
is kind of lost
we're just generating these sequel
strings however it is a new language to
some people particularly if you have
worked with data but it's relatively
easy to get started and kind of growing
a popularity hey thank you it's a quick
question around like I totally see how
being able to parameter parameter eyes
of your sequel queries and stuff
couldn't really help with a development
process but curious to see what tools
you provide to help with like debugging
cuz I'm sure let's say you have an error
in one of your you know downstream
tables and you want to debug what the
source of that error is it's a lot
easier to be able to at least do it for
me anyway it's a lot easier to be able
to read sequel and to see how the data
flowed from one table to the next rather
than reading code where yeah where
things aren't compiled yet so yeah what
tools are there for that yeah so after
compilation you have this massive JSON
object with all of the POC cool that's
generated by the code and in an in the
IDE as well I think we showed it when
you're developing that code and possibly
writing for loops of functions on the
right will show you a kind of real
version of the compiles the pure
compiled sequel that will execute so you
do have you can actually see the actual
pure sequel it's gonna run and let me
show you right run logs we give you a
list of every exact sequence statement
that was executed so when your pipeline
fails you go have a look and you can see
the actual pure sequel statement that
ran and by the error that was caused so
yeah there was we did there are some
efforts to make debugging easier and I
think in general Eid experience the goal
here was to not abstract away sequel too
much we still want to give
visibility into what's actually gonna
execute good so these the IDE can show
you like logs and historical data or
like historical runs and things like
that it's not just for development yes
so I've many should the development
pieces but the run logs the orchestrator
will show you the pure sequel that was
executed
[Music]